you can cope with situations much better
for being a loner i did that shot the
first three weeks of my talk which i
didn't know i bought the world record
you don't look at them as human beings
you just look them out as the job ten
days you're just laying there
um you end up peeing yourself
but they wanted to cut my head off and
kidnap me you become a robot you become
they program you because you know no
different
people that have lost friends
that i've lost through suicide and also
through serving was there any one of
them where you relive quite a lot in
your own mind one that you constantly
think about
yeah yeah
it's hard to talk about
so one person said my father is here
because of this man
so my guest today is a former sniper
sergeant craig harrison who at the time
he had the longest shot ranged
2475 meters using a lapwa magnum 338
which anybody that's broken his record
since then has used a 50 cal and he's
got a fascinating story here's a man
that is an expert at taking people out
80 plus confirms but at the same time
you got a person that's strong
experienced war afghanistan done a bunch
of different things
at the same time he talks about
the effects of ptsd he talks about the
effects of what it did to him in his
personal life on what it is to be a
soldier experiencing those things so the
moment i heard about a story i watched
so many different comments and one of
the videos when i watched the story i
went and read the comments at the bottom
of how many people said direct says one
guy commented and he said the following
i want to set this whole thing up so you
know who you're about to hear from one
of the comments was the following it got
me emotional when i was reading this
comment one guy said
uh
that my uh craig saved my brother's life
in afghanistan he's a gentle loving
human being i'm so sickened to know that
he has been released from active duty
another person said he gave everything
his whole life he literally
uh gave his life for his country he
broke his brain and it took him in all
this stuff that he goes through one
person said my father is here because of
this man so you're hearing from someone
who is loved admired and adored with
that being said craig thank you so much
for making the time for being a guest on
vacation no it's glad to be here glad to
be here so first of all you know
typically in situations like this what's
your reaction when people say to you
thank you for your service how do you
process that when somebody says thank
you for your service
um
how do i answer that
i just say i've just done my job i just
done my job you know it's something that
i joined when i was 16 years old
straight from school because it's
different
american army to the british army you
can join when you're 16 and i did a
year's training
and
i just
you know done my job and
i didn't expect to achieve what i
achieved in my service you know and when
people say you know thank you for your
service i i appreciate that
it's heart touching you know
got it so but it's not something where
in your mind you go to
i wish i would have never served because
i didn't know what the life was going to
be do you ever personally go there you
know because diplomatically we can tell
people yeah it was you know any time no
problem but in your mind you go to
man i i i it's a rough life man that's
not for everybody maybe half the things
i saw i wish i would have never seen do
you ever go there
yeah all the time a lot of time um
i always say
people daydream
you know they always daydream about
holidays and happy things
i dave dream about other things
and that's where i go to my dark place
and the demons
appear and stuff like that and that's
what i try and fight with till today
so still today yeah what are those
events declining or is it still the same
pace
same pace and what are some of the
things you day dream of is it
individuals is it settings is it events
is it
visuals is it a loss of a a person a
friend what do you daydream where do you
go it's a mixture of things it's a
mixture of um scenarios that i've been
in
um close death scenarios that i've been
stuff that i've witnessed through my
sniper scope and
not be able to take this shot but just
observe
the devastation that people do
and
just
people that i've lost friends that i've
lost through suicide and also through
serving you know on tours
everything that everything just it yeah
it's emotional it's emotional
how do you cope with it what's your
mechanism on coping with it is it prayer
is it music is it exercise is it being
around dogs animals music what what is
your route what is your method
two things one is being around my wife
um she is my absolute rock my stone
you know and secondly i go to the gym a
lot
um
and
just lose myself for that hour or two
hours it's nice to lose yourself
you know and not think about things and
just
lose yourself in your music and your
workout and but also to come home
knowing you've got a wife to support you
as well i think that's a a major thing
powerful do you listen to lose yourself
by eminem while you're working out or no
no it's called uh rob bailey in the
hustle standard got it okay so you go
completely different i thought you said
lose yourself you're sitting there
hyping yourself up to eminem but why
don't we go back so 16 years old you go
in do you think 16 is the right age for
a kid to join the military you think
that's the right age
no
no no so what do you think is the right
age i think
okay got it
18 years old 18 years old have a bit of
life experience before you join
you know
straight from school
you become a robot you become they
program you because you know no
different you know no different about
civilian life about getting a job about
money or anything you just join the army
straight away and that's when they
program you and that's when they start
you know
so you're 17 and then you join the
regiment and they start programming you
even more
when you went in let's just say let's go
15 years old if i'm in high school with
you who were you at 15
well say again if i was in school with
you at 15 years old you and i our
buddies were classmates who were you
in school at 15 years old before joining
the military
um quiet a loner
uh didn't i had one friend um he's my
cousin and we're still good friends now
you know i've known my cousin since i
was like five years old and we're still
very tight and we're luckily to go to
the we luckily went to the same school
when we hung out
and um
yeah a bit of a loner i spent more my
time around animals
to be honest with your horses
i've been riding horses since i was five
years old and
instead of
you know going to school
doing doing my work doing my homework
and then concentrate on horses
you know and
that's
that was my life that was my upbringing
do you notice that being a trent amongst
the best of the best of the best snipers
out there where their personality is a
little bit of a loner where they're to
themselves is that a commonality or not
necessarily it is yeah yeah yeah
yeah you you
you can cope with situations much better
you know being a loner you can
stay in a position longer
because you're low you used to being
alone
you know and you work with your number
two
who's close with you and he's right next
to you all the time but you don't talk
you know you get so connected with each
other he knows everything that i'm gonna
do and i know everything he's going to
do
you know and that's how connected you
are and
just to
be quiet
and be of yourself
yeah it's
it's a special art it's you know i bet
what's the longest you you've had to
be quiet in the position not moving
what's the longest you went
uh
one and a half weeks
how long
in afghanistan you're not moving or
standing up walking nothing
no ten days you're just laying there
yes correct
how are you eating how are you peeing
how are you
you end up paying
um you defecate in a in a tupperware jar
so basically you roll over your number
two will put it underneath you you
defecate in it he wraps up you put in
your backpack
you dig a trough between your legs
and then when you pee it sort of like
goes down the trough so it doesn't
hinder you
you eat
dry food all the time because you don't
want to cook you don't want smoke to
give your
signature away or anything so you eat
cold food
and you catnap through the day so you'll
he will he will be on the scope you cut
that for 20 minutes
and then you swap and change and things
like that craig one and a half weeks you
so for one and a half weeks you guys are
not talking you guys are not commun
nothing everything is non-verbal and
you're laying there
that's correct yeah the only um time you
get to speak is when you send sit reps
on the radio just to make sure that you
know everything's going okay um and
you're sending um
sit reps all the time on what the
enemy's doing all the time so that's the
only time you get to speak
how special was this assignment where it
required you to be that patient was this
a special assignment in afghanistan
yeah yeah
to stop the uh afghans getting weapons
um this village we were looking into
um the the afghans were getting really
um a lot of weapon systems into this
village and then they distribute it um
around afghanistan once it gets into
this village so our job was to
gather lifetime information
of what's going on find out who the main
people are and um eventually take them
out did you eventually complete your
mission on this on this in this case
yeah we did yeah yeah
and this was one target or was it
multiple targets multiple multiple how
far were they from you where you're
situated at
closest was about 675 yards and the
furthest was about a mile away
so 675 yards that's seven football
fields away from you the closest
yeah and and where are you are you on
top of a mountain are you by trees are
you in the desert what's the situation
like when what we used we had these um
these cam nets and basically these cam
nets
if you turn them
one way they keep the heat in if you
turn them the other way they keep the
heat out so we managed to cut
a big section of this cam net to cover
ourselves up
and we were on a ridgeline so we're
quite high up elevated looking down into
the village
but we had support
to our um left
of major weaponry but they didn't get
involved it was more of a sniper op than
anything else how many how many people
was it that you took out on this one how
many uh what was the number
oh wow
got it so this so from the moment you
knew was ready this the week and a half
goes by
the the 13 confirms what is the timeline
from the first kill to the 13th one
you're talking
but it all depends where they are at the
same time
it was funny because they had a
um
a big heavy machine gun called a gsc 17
and it's an anti-aircraft gun
and it holds um clips of 30 mil rounds
and there were only four
in afghanistan the the that the
taliban had
and the sas destroyed two
um in theater
and then there were still two out there
and they had one in this village so as
soon as we took the first target out
they they had a rough idea where it came
from the the the from
the noise
and um
they opened up with this asg 17 and took
the whole ridgeline out
you're talking
probably four meters
in front of us was just it was all
splashing up we were getting shot we
just kept our heads down we didn't move
or anything
and then at the night time we
we drew out that position and we went
into another position because we were
you know worried that we had been seen
um or been compromised
but um you're talking 13 people with
probably within a space of
um
within them 10 days or i got you
so it's not like you're sitting still
and then on the 10th day one shows up
boom boom boom boom boom it's not that
that's not the
the no okay i've had an opportunity to
take the target out and it's called
having green guns you see you you say
yeah you've got a green light you've got
green guns you can take the target out
um you can um
eliminate what you you what you
perceived to be the threat at the time
but as a sniper
your main role is everyone thinks of
being a sniper your main role is to
shoot people
it's not it's to gather lifetime
information of the battlefield
interesting
yeah and so when you go in you get as
much information as possible on that
surrounding area and then you go back
you hand all your information over and
they say right then this is what this is
how we're gonna
you know this is how we're gonna play
this out you know then you go back into
your position and you start taking
targets out craig what were the main
places you were deployed in i know it's
a lot of afghanistan i hear about but
what other places were you deployed at
um i've been deployed in bosnia kosovo
um afghanistan and iraq
are all these places you were deployed
you have a
confirmed kill on all these places or no
no iraq and afghanistan got it how
difference was iraq and afghanistan for
you when you were deployed
it was funny because in iraq um
they were it was more urbanized
you know you're talking about
basic city
um and big big built up areas
um so you're talking you gotta hunt
um
then down by your urban so you're in
buildings
you know and some days
the gates of hell would open you know
and some days it would be all quiet
and in afghanistan you're talking about
it's more desert
uh
they have compounds and they have little
villages but nothing built up like iraq
was
got it got it and kosovo bosnia was that
between 97 to 99 was the right direction
yeah i remember that uh i was in the
army when uh the the everybody was
getting deployed to kosovo bosnia and it
was a mess that at that time but uh
going back to the 2475 meters uh that
that uh was that in iraq or was that in
afghanistan afghanistan that was was
that the same 10 days or it's a
different setting
no that was um i did that shot
i did that shot the first three weeks of
my tour
so
i was there for you when you go on tour
you get um
sort of like um
used to the heat and all that before you
get dispersed out to your operations um
so as soon as i got dispersed out to my
operations within three weeks either
took that shot which i didn't know i
bought the world record when did you
know you broke the record who told you
did somebody whisper to you or
no no when i when i came back
to um
england
we we have a medals parade like you get
your ribbons and all that to say welcome
home and the the media is welcome into
the camp
to interview you and talk to you and um
i spoke to this gentleman and i said
that
you know i was a sniper also a sergeant
in charge of these guys and he said can
you tell me a story and i told him the
story of my shot and he said you realize
you built the world record you beat rob
furlon's record
the canadian guy um by you know a long
way and i went no i didn't and when it
went into the papers
that's when we me and my wife got death
threats
and we had to go in hiding for three
years
oh because they put it in the papers
and you know as a sniper you definitely
don't want that
no it was my wife's name my daughter's
name my dog's name
where i lived where i was born where i
was raised up everything everything was
in the papers i'm not funny enough my
wife said i've got a bad feeling about
this i've got a bad feeling about this
and everyone just kept saying to her you
know it's fine it's fine it's fine and
then
um
i there was another clip in the paper
because of the two guys that i shot were
taliban leaders
um they wanted to cut my head off and um
kidnapped me
and uh to just to um teach me a lesson
and so what did you guys have to move
just to make sure you were safe did you
go to a different place so they couldn't
uh yeah we went into secure housing and
then we moved to america for three years
just for that one event and this is two
people you took out right at this event
it's uh yes it is yeah two people and
the 2475 for for some people that maybe
can visually see what that's about a
half a half a mile what we're talking
about right just over a mile and a half
yeah just over a mile and a half is what
we're that's a mile and a half is what
we're talking about so yeah so two there
80 total 13 in that one afghanistan what
was the biggest difference between the
first
kill versus the last one first uh
confirmed kill versus the last one was
there a big difference
emotionally
where the last one is like you know boom
it's a job i'm moving on the first one
you're like oh my gosh
did i do you know what was the biggest
difference for you
that one you
when i first um
when i first got first
shot
and
you know and onto my target you feel
like you're in trouble
you feel like you're in trouble you
think christ i've killed someone
you know um
somebody's gonna tap me on the shoulder
and say you know can we have a quick
word of you you know why did you do this
why did you do that because
i didn't know you know it's my job at
the time and
and then you don't get blase but you
sort of get into the rhythm of things
when you're taking targets out you don't
look at them as human beings you just
look them as as
as the job the operation that you need
to do to take that target out
is there any one of them that you had to
do where there were uh uh
it was so technical because there were
kids involved and you had to try to get
the target that you had uh
in a climate where their kids around and
the only reason i think about this i
think about it from the movie you know
the movie with uh
uh
yeah where i interviewed his wife i had
her on taya
and you know that one scene where
there's kids is like oh my gosh how do i
do it what do i do in this angle was
there ever a
you know situation like that that you
were in
yeah there was yeah in um
in iraq
um in in basel itself where he was in a
place
um a little place called the p-jock and
there was only um
like 12 of us at this location and it
was a police station
basically and
every time every night
the
insurgents used to come up and try and
break into the prison to release all the
people in the prison
so our job was to take the insurgents
out but from
11 o'clock at night or five o'clock in
the morning it was like the gates of
hell
so when you
when five o'clock
comes the marketplace opens
and then you get everyone it's really
busy
you know but you can still see your
targets so you end up tracking them
you end up tracking them you end up
observing you end up
finding out where they go where they
hold up and when the night comes you're
back on that target and where they are
and you end up taking that target out
it's wild just thinking about it you
know on that war was there any any one
of the 80 that
you
afterwards minus the first one because
it's the first one you were experiencing
was there any one of them where you
relive quite a lot in your own mind one
that you constantly think about or no
yeah yeah it's hard to talk about
okay so there is there is something that
in your mind it goes back and is it more
about something where i should have done
it this way i should have done it that
way or was it just a setting that uh you
keep reliving
just
just the whole scenario i should have
done it different you know got it
yeah because i i mean i think about like
you you know in the in uh sports a boxer
okay like right now wilder lost to tyson
for your fury which by the way you sound
like if i close my eyes i'm thinking i'm
talking to tyson fury and you know i
don't know if you guys know each other
if you guys have met or not or you know
no no but uh
so wilder win loses right and he loses
second time and he could have won this
one right he could have won this one
because the couple
one knockout the other one lets you say
he slipped but knockout
so the coaches afterward have to
mentally
get him back in the state many many
boxers when they lose something like
this like when foreman lost he was in
depression for three years and somebody
goes and works with them with these
athletes right the same thing happens in
sports
you know basketball you missed the shot
and you were supposed to win the game
and everybody was relying on you or
election you have to concede call the
other person and say well
congratulations to you and hillary
clinton having to call trump or
something like that i mean this stuff is
public humiliating loss right
when you when you're going through this
what what is the program they have
to
[Music]
coach counsel
the sniper after they had an experience
who did you guys go talk to to calm you
down
was there nobody
no
listen it took me
on that my last tour of
got blown up
also i got um i got my helmet here i got
shot on the helmet so i got shot there
and it came out there
wow
and it knocked me out for about
20 20 seconds i was clean out and that
was an ak-47 short round and that got
shot at probably 100 yards
if that and it knocked me clean out and
then three weeks after that i got blown
up by an ied a 30 kilo anti-tank line
hit my vehicle which i broke both my
arms i got a
brain injury my hips enacted everything
and then um
i was
put back to england
and then six weeks later
they took the casts off my hands made me
do ten press-ups and redeployed me back
into afghanistan
and then when my tour finished i didn't
feel right up here you know when my tour
finished
um
i did 23 years in the british army and
it took me half an hour to get kicked
out
to say goodbye
no thank you no
good service no nothing they just
just kick you out they kicked you out
for what for
uh ptsd uh adjustment disorder
and also my injuries my injuries 23
years and took him half an hour so
how do you feel
how do in your mind how do you feel
about the the way they handled it how do
you feel about
uh the military itself is it more your
frustration is towards an individual or
the entire institution as a whole you
know where is your biggest frustration
with
just the
how the army treat people with ptsd
and how they go about treating it
don't get me wrong my i have a friend
now who's suffering and he's still
serving he's he's in the process of
getting discharged and um
what they've offered him the regiment
is fantastic
but when i
you know eight years ago
it was no nothing like that it was just
you get
kicked out the regiment you get palmed
off onto um like a sick regiment where
they look after all the wounded and
injured soldiers
and then from there they sort your
discharge papers out and you you're gone
you know did they give you 100
retirement is it 100 percent
50 80
30 retirement on 23 years
yeah so not even a hundred percent
disability any of that didn't give you
any of that
it's kind of weird because in us they
started doing 100 this on things like
this
and they were not at one point but 30 so
what did you do after being a sniper how
do you make your money i mean on your
resume you say hey i'd like to get a job
here what are you great at i'm great at
taking people out two thousand you know
you know what do you go do do you become
a manager somewhere what is
what what job qualifies you to go and
say i'm qualified to do this job
i'm lucky i work for a company at the
moment that um
understand about ptsd and understand and
i'm probably the
third fourth personnel was in the
military sort of like being discharged
and they're really good and i just work
in a factory basically i work in a
factory and that's all i do now and i
sit in my bench making parts
for um machinery and
that's all i do and it's it's my is it's
my numbing but it's it's a job and i'm
lucky to have a job and i'm lucky that
this company is taking me on and they
looked after me and i appreciate that
well good for them man for doing that
you know the companies that do things
like that
uh uh i i spoke to a group in dallas who
were former paratrooper navy seals delta
you know all the main ones ranger all
the big ones in the u.s that we have
right
and
these are sharp looking guys like you
sharp guys strong guys and having a hard
time getting a job they had a hard time
getting a job after their career because
what do you see on your resume you know
although some of them like a sniper i
can imagine a sniper are you a math guy
or are you somebody that's good with
numbers i'm assuming you have to be as a
sniper right because the whole thing is
math and angle yeah but since i've
got a tbi um
little things
like stress me i get stressed a lot
lately you know i get um
frustrated with myself because i can't
do much like i used to like um this
november i'm i'm having my hips replaced
you know so i won't be able to go into
the gym so that's more stress and more
frustration with me you know but
the the going back to the army the
army's getting much better at how
they're dealing with things the british
army and the way they're handling it
yeah
nowadays they're getting much better you
know i think they're learning by their
mistakes you can't go back and reapply
for a hundred percent
i did you know what i went for tribunal
and um
i walked in
and it was all done by video link
because i was in america at the time so
i had to go to baltimore to do a video
link to england
and uh the the woman judge said to me
she looked at me and she goes well mr
harrison
he seemed a very capable young man
and that was it and
he was got he got pushed out of court
yeah i lost it i lost my tribunal
i i don't i don't understand that part
you know a guy gives uh more than half
of his life to your country puts his
life on the line gets shot up on you you
do all these things that people are just
not willing to do and then
all right hey thank you awesome all the
best you good luck here's thirty percent
that part i don't get uh
there were certain situations in the u.s
army where guys left
and they had scenarios obviously not as
extreme as yours and they left at 30
percent 15 years later they went back
and applied they got the 100 15 years
later but during that 15 they were not
getting it so i'm curious to know if the
british army will ever consider doing
that
let me let me ask a different question
in regards to yourself when you're in
there
you're you're looking at the taliban as
enemies you're looking at these guys as
enemies
now that you're disconnected from it and
you're you're this is not your
day-to-day stuff
how do you view
both
uh folks in iraq afghanis and the
taliban obviously i'm asking this
question because the last 60 days 90
days you know the world's turned upside
down in afghanistan with the way america
left and there's a lot of different
conversations around it but how do you
view
from personal experience afghanistan
iraq and the taliban
i don't want to get too political about
it but it's um it's hurtful it's her
fault you know you put
in afghanistan for instance 20 years of
infrastructure that the americans have
put in the english are put in we pulled
out the americans put more more more in
there and then
it just went wrong it just went wrong
and to know that
i've lost people out there to know that
i've
coming back to england and i've had
friends commit suicide
because of afghanistan
it makes you angry it makes you angry
and it makes you angry towards
towards the government really that they
haven't done much more to defend it and
not even an apology not even a
i i do believe that and our local papers
out here they had um mothers
of
um sons that have been killed out there
wanting an apology off the prime
minister
and um which they never got
you know i never got i understand it's
their job and that's our job out there
to do a job
you know but it's like doing a job and
you've come away with nothing
really
yeah i mean
and that's got to be especially uh
uh more personal to you because you you
put a lot of your uh deployment there uh
for somebody who's never had direct
dealings with the taliban they don't all
they know is what the news says you know
one channel says
they're evil people another channel says
they're changing one channel says
they're marrying 11 year old girls grown
40 year old men are married in 11 years
and you know you should read these
stories and there's no way in the world
this can be true this has got to be
there's no way the world's going to
allow these types of things to happen
another publication says no that's true
that's exactly what's happening
what was your direct experience on how
these folks are are they as evil
as
we read about in many different
publications
yeah
in my eyes in my eyes i i'm not
they're
a different breed different breed
you know but i feel
like you said that like you've heard
that they need to change i think they
need to change they need to change to
get the afghan people on site so
you know so things need to change
for for the better not for the worse do
you think they will
you think you think the taliban will
change
i think they they will just put a smoke
screen up to say
you know
we're going to do this we promise this
we promise that or it will go all quiet
and then
you know
they've done what they've done
it's a sad situation man seeing what's
going on over there um yeah it's it's a
it's a hard thing to talk about
i bet especially for somebody like you
yeah
uh
last couple things here before we wrap
up you know uh what is the biggest
difference between you know you using a
lapua magnum you know the 338 versus a
50 cal when you're shooting something
that far what is the level of difficulty
using a 338 versus a 50 cal
a 50 car can go 4ks
so that can go
that can go up to three miles it can go
in a straight line
you know and and it's designed it's a
bigger round mine's only a small round
like i said before my rifle was only
meant to go 1500 meters that's the the
max distance of my rifle
so you have to calculate that the
you have to calculate i mean this is
pure geometry right if you have to
calculate the
incline and the decline
uh uh
wow so if you so if you shoot a bullet
say for instance
at 100 meters you should put it now that
bullet will go flat that bullet will
stay flat up to 300 to 350 meters
but just for just for argument's sake if
it did rise up that bullet did rise up
the highest point of that bullet would
be three quarters so it'd be at
70 meters would be the highest point in
that bullet
and then it would start dropping so a
mile and a half thousand yards
highest point would be 700
before it starts dropping so you've got
to work out where it's going to drop
and and how many tries did it take for
you to hit this target a mile and a half
well in the morning um i saw that there
was a dicker
a guy with nikon chatter
radio
and uh i saw the glint the antenna
and i can see the taliban
where i was
waiting to ambush the patrol going in
so i took nine shots to get there to hit
the compound wall
and i was bracketing it's called
bracketing when you fire the first shot
and you go okay lift up a bit more yeah
but
what everyone forgets i was stood up
when i fired these shots so i wasn't
lying down
i was lent against the wall
is there a difference
um it's harder
because you've got the recall the going
back you know the wall kept crumbling
you got the undulating of the ground as
well
it was just a nightmare but yeah i
managed to bracket and
one round hit the compound wall
and then the dicker's head went down
and i had an interpreter with me who had
a radio tuned into the taliban frequency
and he said to me that
the taliban are blind now because they
can't see what's going on
so that was that was roughly about 11
o'clock in the morning i did that shot
and then
when
i when i took these up the guys out it
was roughly about one o'clock
the contact lasted for about two hours
standing up
you
[Music]
i guess the word i would use is
calibrated but you're saying bracketing
so
and
that's that's insane to be thinking
about that and a weapon that only goes
and you went you know that's uh
another thousand meters more than that
do you have a favorite weapon yourself
from over the years
um
that rifle is good that's right it's a
solid rifle yeah you know what i mean
and it's proven to do the job and it
does the job well it's got a lot of
stopping power as well
do you still go to the range today or no
no i don't know we do because my ptsd
they're quite strict in england about
shooting but when i was in america i
used to go to the range all the time oh
so it doesn't it doesn't bother you if
you go even today if you were to go you
you would have gone if if they allowed
you
it's funny really because in america
they if you got ptsd or you got some
sort of stress from the army they say
instead of going to the cinema instead
of going for lunch let's go to the range
and if you see
everyone just goes to the range and has
a good time blowing rounds and all that
so not really doesn't sometimes it does
you know when i look for a scope i get
like a little sharp image sometimes and
i shake it off and then there's a crack
on
you know
but um
yeah but i don't i don't shoot anymore
do you watch any of the movies are you a
guy that watches any military movies or
no no no i end up critiquing it
and that can't be right
no that's wrong no that's wrong
you know
what have you seen anything that was
very like you're like that's the closest
thing i've seen that yeah that was
somewhat believable anything you've seen
there's a british film called kajaki
kajaki
yeah that's a good film and that's
that's like the most accurate depiction
of what it looks like
um it's nothing to do with snipering but
it's to do with um
a patrol um in a post
in um iraq and that's that's i would say
yes more like it was like
got it and and
do you have any kids i don't know if you
have any kids or not
i've got two daughters two daughters
okay
if you had a son
and he's thinking about joining the
military to be a sniper what would you
tell him
get a trade
get a trade join
yeah join the engineers
you know join summit where you become a
carpenter you got bricklayer you know a
battle engineer when you can drive all
these machineries and everything so when
you do come at the armed forces because
they don't look after you when you come
out you've got something to fall back on
and like you said
these special forces guys can't get jobs
you know i'm lucky
but
if you as an engineer and you left with
all your licenses you can drive big
arctic lorries and you can build a fence
you can build a wall you're made so
that's what i would say to my son got it
and and to to anybody else that's
joining the military sniper do you look
at the job of a sniper as a
you know admirable thing like oh my gosh
you know the
this person's a sniper is that how you
look at it or you kind of like like i
know what it is to be a sniper i lived
that life for 23 years there is a it's
not a life you want to live where do you
go yourself when you think about it
they say
in the army you do trades so you do a
sniper would be a trade
a paratrooper or be a trade
and i say snipering is a curse
yeah because it it scars you it scars
you
what a what a perspective man sniper
ring is a
is a curse so uh uh to wrap up craig
book longest kill
uh uh can you can you take a moment and
tell us about the book the longest kill
yeah well i wrote the book because um i
wanted to put people right about the
shots because um i think the americans
did something on youtube where they had
me lying down and everything i just
wanted to put everyone right but i just
couldn't do one chapter in the book so i
did it about my life story you know when
i was a child my childhood
you know which was good
and then from there joining the army
joining the foreign legion doing prize
fighting uh
just things that i'd done priced
fighting you know yeah i did price
fighting for a while
for money
wrong place at the wrong time how was
that how was the experience of price
fighting
painful
i bad
i bet yeah you just you did it for money
he did it for money i i met this person
uh that i knew and he introduced me to
it
and um so i did it for a while
and then um
you sort of
yeah you become a bit painful after a
while so you sort of give it up
who do people say you look like i got
two people i think you look like i'm
curious to know what you say
who do people say you look like anybody
or no
uh is it matt dillon
well i can see that one 100 i can see
that one but i got a combination of two
cats and by the way people that are
watching this say yes or no if i'm if it
doesn't make any sense say pat give it a
thumbs down if it makes sense give it a
thumbs up
but i see a
a connor and a dan bilzerian i don't
know if you know these two characters
maybe you know conor mcgregor you may
know him yeah
but dana's a different guy you gotta and
they're both obviously you know this is
these are uh uh studs that we're talking
about uh but uh interesting life you've
lived man very very interesting life
you've lived and i i appreciate you
coming out here we're gonna put the link
to your book below for folks to be able
to go pick up as well but more than
anything else just listening to your
story
uh and still doing your best to have
this attitude and going about your life
and to have your wife in your life where
your coloner your rock and exercising
that is a form of uh uh
losing yourself for that hour or two in
the gym
uh it's it's honorable to hear a man
that's served and is willing to talk
about it and is as humble as you are i
appreciate you coming on and being a
guest on valuetainment i really enjoy
this time with you
thank you i appreciate talking anytime
brother take care of yourself thank you
thank you very much
let me put it to you this way every time
i do an interview the guys that are here
i asked them so tell me what you think
about it we were all speechless by his
story that's all i can tell you and i
don't know about you i'm curious to know
what you took away from this because i'm
sure you were also speechless a week and
a half with your partner not moving
nothing could you do that for a week
imagine a job where you have to lay
there as a grown man or a grown woman
for a week and a half blown away if you
like the interview give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and if you
like this i did an interview also with
another sniper who had 33 confirmed
kills i believe he was the first african
american sniper
from a unit
you need to hear a story fascinating
story you got a couple million views and
it's another one of those stories where
you're going to be flabbergasted by his
life of a sniper so if you've not seen
that click over here thank you everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you